the way that this movie is shot is
absolutely beautiful and it's so big and
so brought in as stuff that you're not
really not gonna pick up on regular
screens you're only gonna pick up on how
much Sam went and did all the testing
there the other day and said it's
looking spectacular
vojta OTO P has done an amazing job
there are movies that are made for
enormous screens but when you watch it
on an IMAX it is an incredible sensation
it's thrilling and exciting just wrapped
up - and you're holding on your seat
are all the elements like a symphony
made all together because we have action
with violence but in the cinematography
way every man's I was glued to the
screen I was watching what's so
fantastic about that the big screen is
that you catch details that you don't
see on a smaller screen one of some
specialities is sound
we've spent a huge amount of time
getting that right and this flan sounds
very special the sound is fantastic
and it's fun it's great fun you just
won't get the full experience if you
don't see our lilacs and that's an
honest answer that's speaking as a fan
this organization you know what it's
called its name is Spectre
you